foreign
we've seen some very dramatic images in
Syria residents found a crying newborn
baby still connected by the umbilical
cord to her mother and a warning that
we're about to show you the images of
that infant pulled from the rubble
the miracle baby was born under her
family's collapsed home following the
devastating earthquake the newborn was
rushed to safety and is now receiving
treatment in hospital her mum is
believed to have gone into labor as the
first earthquake hit neither of the
girl's parents nor her four siblings are
believed to have survived according to
locals in the small North Syrian town of
hinderas
foreign
town of bisnia a crowd cheered as three
children and a man were pulled alive
from their homes according to local
reports Rescuers spent more than a day
searching for a family trapped under the
debris the survivors were immediately
taken to an ambulance for medical
assistance